c'est le moment il est temps d'écouter
la colère du peuple français gronder par
la voix du procureur général de la
république des proches française
m
des parents et en ce moment il met son
électro sur la bavette
il va passer à l'attaqué et au justement
avant toute chose mesdames et messieurs
qu'il me soit permis à titre
exceptionnel de demander à la cour
d'observer une minute de silence pour
honorer la mémoire des espoirs déçus de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing
monsieur giscard d'estaing qu'il ya sept
ans exactement emménagé à l'elysée avec
sa femme ses lordon boutonneux c'est
vasarely ces chiens de luxe et son
canari auvergnats une minute de silence
attention c'est fini merci le roi mort
vive le roi
nous entrons enfin mesdames et messieurs
dans une ère de liberté
c'est à dire une heure au cours de
laquelle on va pouvoir dire que
mitterrand est un conte sans risquer de
se faire censurer par giscard c'est sale
[Applaudissements]
on va pas s'gêner françaises français
belges belge monsieur l'animateur des
grandes fêtes populaires sous la pluie
[Applaudissements]
mon asperges je vous appelle menace
perse parce que depuis tout petit dans
les asperges et toujours réclamé la tête
c'est du mont asperges montée nord du
fado mesdames et messieurs les jurés
public chéri mon amour pour ceux qui
douteraient encore de l'extrême
singularité de ce tribunal d'exception
je signale que nous sommes ici la seule
cour d'assises au monde qui soit capable
de mener à bien un jugement sans avoir
besoin d'accuser en effet quand je suis
arrivé à mon bureau m'apprêtant à mettre
au clair les éléments qui devait me
permettre de requérir au nom du
ministère public
j'y ai trouvé une note manuscrite
émanant du bureau des assesseurs est
ainsi libellé pierre on est dans la
merde on ne sait pas qui on juge
finalement aujourd'hui ça fait rien
comment son réquisitoire je te rapelle
une signée gilles et marina d'ubs et
attaqué le bureau des assesseurs
troublant mais alors bien me tripote où
va la france
où va la france ans qu'elle habite la
république va t'elle s'engloutir si on
laisse ainsi ces deux fléaux de la
balance armé le bras de la justice ou la
robe austère de laquelle la chine ne
s'agite fébrilement les deux les deux
matches les deux plateaux les ii
plateaux les deux plateaux bridas corp
pauvre france tu es tombé bien bas
depuis la fin de l'amitié
franco-allemande en 1944 et ce n'est pas
en changeant de chauves tous les sept
ans que ça va s'arranger
à 1940 je me vois encore je me vois
encore il n'ya plus de frontière entre
l'alsace et l'allemagne
il n'y a plus que les deux bras du
fleuve profond à europe je vais et je
viens entre terrain enfin enfin bon ne
sachant pointe encore que c'était
veulent à ce qui allait comparaître
aujourd'hui à lège collaborer avec les
deux assesseurs chafouin de cette
guignolade et me mettre à parler de
n'importe quoi pour occuper le temps
d'antenne qui met un parti et bien non
mesdames et messieurs les jurés je ne
vous parlerai pas de n'importe quoi il
ya justement un sujet grave qui me tient
à coeur depuis longtemps et peu de jours
me reste avant de l'aborder
voici je suis pour l'abolition
l'abolition de quoi de la peine de mort
ça va pas la tête non je suis pour
l'abolition du mois de juin le mois de
juin est nul
le mois de juin la honte de notre
société et la sagesse populaire ne s'est
pas trompé qui n'a jamais accordé le
moindre de ses dictons ou maxime à semoy
ridicule en effet on dit en avril ne te
découvre pas d'un fil
en mai fais ce qu'il te plaît en octobre
et starhub en novembre en sont membres
en janvier pour les membres arrêtés
l'arrêt au cercle et maxence brulard en
janvier fait ça sous l'évier etc
mais en juin en juin a rien qui dans ce
tribunal peut citer un seul dicton
populaire ayant trait au mois de juin
qui peux seulement me citer une rue
mollien mais s'ils veulent inscrire coin
coin coin c'est loin c'est pas le lien
yap a dream en loin dans ce pays
françaises français
maintenant que 6 cars et virait grâce au
coup du père francois mitterrand
[Applaudissements]
nous devons unir toutes les forces
populaires de ce pays et exigé
l'abolition immédiate du mois de juin
avec la femme et le péril jaune le mois
de juin est le pire ennemi de l'homme
aussi loin qu'on remonte dans l'histoire
de l'humanité le mois de juin reste le
seul mois de l'année où il ne s'est
jamais rien passé d'exceptionnel à moins
bien sûr qu qualifie de dates
historiques le honteux 18 juin 40 qui
marque le début de la collaboration la
pire celle d'un général français félon
avec l'ennemi héréditaire anglais
l'anglais qui roule à gauche et qui non
content d'avoir fait cuire jeanne d'arc
continue de nos jours encore à faire
bouillir la viande rouge au mépris des
règles les plus élémentaires de la
tradition culinaire française
camarades je dis non les procureurs sont
pas encore un tribunal du peuple
je dis non au mois de juin car le mois
de juin n'est rien il n'a aucune
consistance saisonnière ce n'est plus
printemps ce n'est pas l'été c'est rien
les cinq ont fait au mois de juin sont
nulles sainte blandine tellement moche
qu'elle faisait peur aux lions
saint-prosper patron des mac
saint-antoine-de-padoue dix de retrouvés
tous des minables le mois de juin cette
trente jours 30 jours sans une seule
paire de seins devant qui s'agenouille
et aucun jour férié d'une de ce nom ne
viendrait aussi cette image lamentable
du mois de juin le seul jours fériés du
mois de juin c'est la pentecôte
et ça tombe toujours un dimanche et cela
est grave camarades française camarades
français car une robe beige démago et
compléter ses camarades de me bourdon
car enfin je vous le demande si tous les
jours fériés de l'année tombait un
dimanche que resterait-il de notre
civilisation occidentale moderne
vous me direz il ya le lundi de
pentecôte mais c'est un jour férié
catholique et aucun travailleur laïque
de ce pays qui a tant fait pour la
séparation de l'église et de l'état
aucun travailleur de france ne
s'abaisserait à faire le jeu de la
calotte en faisant le pont un jour
catholique
un mois après l'élection d'un président
de gauche vous rendez compte c'est pas
possible
en vérité je vous le dis vive le pont
oui mais vive le pont laïque
que deviendrait le français moyen sans
le pont le pont en études pointent la
plus grande conquête sociale de la
france depuis 1936 qu'est ce qui fait
bouger les français qu'est ce qui les
fait courir et s'agitent et bobby sands
la pologne le salvador l'afghanistan les
enfants qui crèvent de faim de
tamanrasset à kampala non scellées peau
d'un bout à l'autre de l'année la france
vivre exulte et s'exalte parce que du
1er janvier au 31 décembre
la france est peuplée d'une bande de
pont n'est ce pas jaune sauf justement
pendant ce qu'on demande bien qui n'a
qu'un pont alors que mais en a trois et
moi j'en ai 4
je ne souhaite à personne ce qui m'est
arrivé au milieu de l'année 73 je crois
cette année là j'ai pris des vacances au
mois de juin mais quelle horreur
comment décrire la désolation d'une
plage de juin où l'homme air hagard et
solitaire sous le soleil
arpentant le sable sans l'espoir de
rencontrer ce chaleureux contacts entre
son pied et le ventre de son voisin de
celle aime abba l'étalement des vacances
vivre l'étalagé des vacanciers qui a
plus fait pour la renommée du mois
d'août que l'était l'âge des étrons pour
le prestige d'hara kiri
oui française française abolissons le
mois de juin qui mérite notre mépris
je sais que madame tata et madame melba
qui m'écoutent ne sont pas de cet avis
mais madame melba ne mérite qu'une pêche
sur le pif et madame tatin une tape dans
la gueule mort au mois de juin mois ci
pompeux qu'on a même donné son nom à
maréchal de france le temps qu'ils
mettent un parti touchant à sa femme
tu es trop tard pour moi il est trop
tard pour des bosses débroussailler le
cas de cet homme qui est l' horrible
mi homme mi communiste
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais la sagesse populaire ne s'y trompe
pas qui vole un oeuf valence qui
j'avais noté et qu'allons nous devenir
sans eux
georges wolinski je vais parler
longtemps vous n'avez pas interrompu
vais-je maintenant coupé un homme qui ne
m'a pas interrompu je vais me gêner
qu'on lui coupe le veulent inscrire
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais simplement ajouter une pièce
au dossier je voudrais en aucun cas que
l'on considère ça comme un événement
important que je suis né le 28 juin
[Rires]
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est à moi
nul fait non non
[Musique]